In this problem, a membrane lined
landfill generates a peak leate flow of
1 CFS that must be conveyed in a full
flow HDP circular pipe. Manning's
roughness n= 0.01
and the pipe slope is 1%.
The design also requires that the flow
velocity when conveying 1 cfs not exceed
5 ft pers.
Which of the following nominal pipe
diameters in inches is the smallest that
satisfies both the flow and the velocity
constraints?
So in theory, this is a problem that
could be on either the water resources
or the environmental exam, but given
that it's landfill lee related, it's
much more likely that it's going to be
on the environmental exam. So, we're
going to use the equation from that
exam's reference manual.
So, if you search Manning, this will
bring you to chapter 1, the Manning's
equation on page 9. And that's going to
be equal to V = K / N * the hydraulic
radius to 2/3*
the slope raised to the 1/2.
If we keep in mind that Q= VA
and K= 1.486
for US units,
we can further expand on this equation.
So instead of solving for V, we can
instead solve for Q
by adding the area term into Manning's
equation. This is pretty common, so
you've probably already seen it before.
And it's going to be Q = KN * the area
now* the hydraulic radius raised to the
2/3 * the slope to the 1/2.
Furthermore, we can identify what the
minimum required cross-sectional area
would be for this problem if we divide
the peak leate flow of 1 cfs by the
maximum allowable velocity of 5 ft pers.
And as we can see here, the minimum
required area of the pipe would be 0.2
square ft.
So now that we've established which form
of Manning's equation we need to use
given the types of terms we have
available to us, we can write these out
and begin to fill them in. We can
experiment to see which pipe sizes meet
the criteria described above by simply
plugging in the diameter of those pipes
into Manning's equation.
So we can see that Q= 1.486
over
Manning Zen of 0.01 01
times the equation for area of a
circular pipe which over here we'll
write down a =<unk> * d ^2 4. So in the
equation we can write<unk>
* 0.5 ft^2 / 4 which is what 62 is going
to simplify to
times the equation for hydraulic radius
which is just going to be area over
weded perimeter.
So that's going to be<unk> *.5^2 over 4
again over the wided perimeter equation
is just p<unk> * diameter. So at the
bottom we'll do<unk> * 0.5 ft.
And this entire
fraction is going to be raised to the
2/3.
And then finally the slope of 1%
aka 1 over 100 equals 0.01
as it fits within the equation
and that's square rooted.
So this is a little bit annoying to plug
into your calculator, but you can
simplify a little bit to make it a
little bit easier. Now, assuming you do
this correctly and don't mess up any
terms in your calculator, you should get
a flow of 0.73 cubic feet per second
when the pipe diameter is 6 in. Since
this is less than our peak leate flow of
1 cfs, there is not enough flow able to
be delivered through this pipe. So, we
have to look at the next one on the
list.
So we will simply rewrite the Manning's
equation again swapping out the 6 in for
8 in.
So Q is going to be equal again to 1.486
over Rn of 0.01* 01
* our area which is equivalent to<unk> *
8 / 12
quantity^ 2ar
/ 4
times the hydraulic radius aka the area
over the wetted perimeter. So that's
going to be p<unk> * 8 over 12^ squar
again quantity over 4
over<unk>
* 82
red is just supposed to help highlight
what's changed between the equation
above and this current equation.
And then our slope is going to be 0.01
again.
And as is before,
some of our terms will cancel out. And
if you can plug the rest successfully
into your calculator, you should see
that flow is equal to 1.52
cubic feet per second.
So the 8 in pipe can achieve a peakle
shape flow greater than the amount
required for our landfill. So this will
pass.
Now that we know it meets the flow
requirement, we have to check to see if
it also meets the design constraint for
the velocity.
Now, when checking to see if the
velocity is going to be less than 5 ft
per second, it's important to remember
that we aren't going to use the pipes
peak flow as is derived from Mannings,
but instead just the value for the peak
leate flow that is actually going to be
coming from the landfill.
So, that would be an easy mistake you
could make here.
But we're not going to make that
mistake. Instead, we're going to write
out again that V equals Q / A
plugging in our Q of 1 CFS given in the
problem statement
and divided by the equation for area of
the pipe which is going to be p<unk> * 8
12^ 2 / 4
giving us a velocity of 2.9 ft pers.
As we can see, this does satisfy the
velocity constraints. So, the 8-in pipe
would be acceptable for this design. So,
the hardest part of this problem really
isn't the concept given that the problem
statement already tells you you're going
to need Manning's equation. Instead,
it's just going to be manually plugging
things in and keeping Manning's equation
organized.
Also, we got lucky by guessing that it
was one of the smaller two pipes. So, we
started with six and then moved on to
eight. Whereas,
we could have started with 12 and worked
our way down. So, that's a little bit of
a tossup as well. But, this problem's
not very difficult. Just do your best to
stay organized and you should be able to
calculate out to the right answers. And
that's it.